[Music]
the mesquita has always been a spiritual
place but has not always been occupied
by the same religion nowhere else in the
world will you find a cathedral built
inside the walls of a mosque originally
the site of a temple to the Roman god
Janus the mesquita was built as a mosque
after Cordova came under Moorish rule in
the late 7th century then in 1236 the
city of Cordoba came under Christian
rule and the mesquita was converted to a
church four centuries later a cathedral
was constructed in its center and it
became a home for the town's Roman
Catholics while the cathedral is an
example of classic Catholic Baroque
architecture the majority of the
mosquitoes construction is a result of
the work of Islamic architects features
like 856 columns and symmetrical arches
give the illusion of infinite space
these elements are examples of why the
mesquita is considered one of the
greatest accomplishments in Islamic
architecture in the world today it is a
unesco world heritage site over a
million people visit every year and
after all its history it is now seen as
a site of religious significance to both
Catholics and Muslims
you
you
[Music]